following up with this hypothetical
subject when you do bring the camera out
let's say you've met with them three
times and you've built a rapport and
there's a level of trust there but you
notice that they've changed a little in
front of the camera maybe they're super
on maybe they're second-guessing
themselves how do you get them and this
is a horrible terminology but I can
think of no other verbal diarrhea just
get it out of them and I know that's
really just how do we how do you get
that acting this out of them sort of
that performance or nervousness or
whatever it is because you're trying to
get to that sort of yeah it's a core of
who they are and everybody has their own
way of acting once that camera first
comes out and again yeah horrible term I
would say I would say that I mean that
is a bit of a challenge when you've you
know you've traveled halfway around the
world let's say to spend time with
somebody and they're not being
themselves on camera they're they're
acting or performing that is that is
that's that happens as hard as you try
for it not to happen are there any
tricks you do you know one one thing
that helps I think that I find it helps
quite a bit is I really feel like I
really feel like you know asking asking
the same question to them repeatedly so
you ask them a question you know why do
you do what you do and you get you get
an answer and then an hour later why do
you do what you do why do you do what
you do and you keep asking them
eventually they're gonna you're gonna
wear them down and they're gonna stop
putting on a show because it's hard to
put on a show in front of the camera
they didn't I mean then really get sort
of tiring we've had we've had shoots
where we did we had the camera I've had
the camera in my hand where I wasn't
even rolling because I knew we're not
so I just stopped rolling because
there's no reason that bring all this
footage back that we're not going to use
and then once I feel like they've kind
of let their guard down and they're
being themselves more then we start
rolling so yeah I mean there's a lot of
I when I was younger I spent some time
in front of the camera and I did some
acting and really enjoyed it when I was
a little kid and so I definitely have
spent time in front of the camera and I
understand the fact that it's on it's an
unnatural place to be and people can get
a little nervous in front of the camera
so we just do the best we can to take
take the mystery out of it and to try to
and to try to allow people to just act
themselves and you know it's funny
something happened on our on our most
recent film on if you build it got it
never had happened before but it was
just I'd never heard this before but it
was something I'll never forget one of
the subjects in our film is a guy named
Matt Miller and he's an architect and a
teacher in our film and his mom lives
very far away from him I think she's
like 2,000 miles away from where he
lives and they don't see each other that
often but she told me that we gave her a
copy of the film and she told me that a
lot of times she'll watch the movie just
just to be around him and she feels like
our movie is math I mean that's how she
described it that our movie really just
captured who he is and that when when
the movie is on sometimes you'll turn
the volume down but she feels like she's
around him I mean that to us is what
we're trying to achieve we want to tell
great stories but we don't want to
change our subjects to do that I think
there's great stories in real life
and if you if you're patient enough you
know you can you can really capture
those stories without changing them
you